uh now i've got some breaking news uh to  bring you  uh this is the big news today dina asher  smith we  knew that she had failed to make the 100  meters  final this afternoon a huge shock in  itself  but now confirmation that she is  pulling out of the 200 meters  with a hamstring injury you can see  at the bottom of your screen there uh  some words from her i think i'm likely  to pull out  of the 200.  she's been told i had conversations  with her coach and i understand her  coach  has told her it's a nose a huge  disappointment there for team gb and of  course uh for dina asha smith  flying the flag for britain out of the  100 meters after failing to qualify  and now out of the 200 metres final  with a hamstring injury